The Joe Rogan experience.
Have you had any psychedelic experiences yet?
I haven't and I was so tempted.
We used to,
we started the interview talking about my chocolate.
Shamanism.
You haven't said anything I haven't in,
but I was real excited.
Want to?
I don't think so.
And I'll tell you why.
So I listened to the Michael Palin interviews and he had his great conversation
with Sam Harris and I really think that this silhouette's Ivan stuff is,
is real and just got d criminal.
I know in Denver,
I was just there the other day.
Um,
but as I said before,
I think that the ultimate drug is us.
And so for me,
I would rather,
and I definitely think that our awareness that does,
it doesn't encompass everything that is knowable.
Everything that we,
that we could know,
but we have ourselves in and if we want to get out of,
of those limitations,
certainly drugs are ways that people have used for,
for many thousands of years.
But when you take the drug,
you're like taking the drug and then you're not taking the drug.
Like I would rather,
what does that mean?
It's like if you're taking psilocybin,
you're having this great experience,
but then tomorrow you're not taking silicide urban and so kind of your
consciousness has narrowed.
My aspiration would be to recognize that the drug is us,
that if we want to expand our consciousness,
there are all kinds of ways,
whether it's meditation or awareness or just you know,
simple appreciation.
That's when I do these cacao ceremonies.
What I say is like you have this cacau in front of you,
but it's not just this like think of the person in Honduras who planted the
seed.
The person who watered that see the person who took the plant,
the person who paved the road to bring the plan.
And I just,
I just think that we can expand our consciousness through our own means and then
we always have access.
I hear what you're saying,
but you're saying this from a person that's never had,
so I know experienced.
It's really preposterous.
You did experience silicide and can do to,
yeah.
You definitely wouldn't be saying it this way.
You also wouldn't be thinking,
then you take it and then you're not on it anymore because it's profoundly
influential for the,
your perspective in regards to the whole rest of your existence.
There's many people that have had psychedelic experiences to think about it as a
rebirth.
Yeah.
That they've gone through this and changed.
So,
well,
why would you have this rigid thought process about drugs and not drugs,
but yet you don't have it about cow,
which is a mild drug.
Yeah.
And so I,
you're right that it may not be entirely consistent.
Some of the people you've described are good friends of mine who've really done
it,
and I've really,
I've talked to them about it and I'm,
I'm endlessly curious,
so why don't you do it?
The reason is so far,
I have been on this journey to see what's possible within my self and I'm still
on that journey.
I'm not,
I don't want to close off any possibility for any assume that it would close
things off.
That's what's confusing.
Yeah.
It's just opening you up to a new experience at other people have found to be
profoundly influential.
Yeah.
So,
so far you're very resistant to this.
Like you,
you're not talking,
you're like,
yeah,
yeah.
Like you can't wait to come back to your own rationale,
your respect.
You know,
it's funny,
I will,
I will come back to this perspective of a person who hasn't experienced
anything.
You're so right.
And just,
I think it's such a great point because I'm very close with actually the,
with the Tibetans.
One of my closest friends is the prime minister of the Tibetan exile
governments.
I've been many times to John Sala in India.
I've met with his holiness,
the Dalai Lama many times and the most incredible thing about meeting with these
guys.
And they,
they are all people who've found these incredible states of,
of heightened consciousness so much that their brains are changed when they go
into the,
the MRI machines.
But when you have a conversation with them,
it's not like we do like,
exactly.
And thank you for calling me out.
Like you say something,
I've already in my head countered what you're saying before you're finished
saying,
and I'm like,
why you kept saying,
right,
exactly.
Yeah.
Which probably means,
yeah,
you made me on a little uncomfortable,
which is good.
That's what we,
what we want.
And these guys,
it's like you talk to them and they would just be so tuned in to what you were
saying and they would just kind of think about it.
Then you'd finish and then they'd kind of look up.
And then,
because we're Americans,
we,
we want,
you know,
somebody stops speaking like you have to if you don't speak right away.
And then there was like a minute and then it's like you're kind of looking at
round,
was it me?
Did I say it's,
and then they would come back with this incredibly thoughtful thing.
So I,
you're right.
You know,
I don't want to close off any possibility.
There are many different things that we could,
uh,
could do.
The Path that I have been on and certainly with this Cook County,
right.
Cacau is like a,
a mild,
I mean,
not a huge one,
but like a,
a mild drug and life is a mild drug.
Um,
so Simon's not very mild.
Yeah,
no.
In my friends who have done it,
have said exactly what you said.
They say,
I have a,
a good friend of mine who,
uh,
who did it.
Um,
and then he said,
it just,
it showed me a path to a different identity,
a different consciousness.
And now he said,
I don't do psilocybin,
but I do daily meditation,
but I can see where I'd like to go,
what's possible.
So I get that.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of different substances out there that have very similar
profound effects.
Yeah.
Um.